[Música]
Hola Esto es África 7 días el programa
donde les presentamos la actualidad del
continente africano Mi nombre es Amanda
Y estos son los titulares en el este de
la República democrática del Congo Los
Rebeldes del movimiento
m-23 siguen ganando terreno la República
democrática del Congo acusa a Ruanda de
apoyar a este grupo mientras las
tensiones entre ambos países aumentan
analizamos la situación con josep Arroyo
miembro del grupo de estudios africanos
de la Universidad Autónoma de Madrid la
cop 27 máxima cita climática mundial
empezó en Egipto el evento tiene lugar
en África donde los efectos del cambio
climático se dejan sentir con fuerza las
medidas que podrían ser adoptadas tras
esta conferencia tendrían un fuerte
impacto en este continente y dedicamos
la última parte de nuestro programa al
músico y activista nigeriano
Quizá es uno de los más importantes de
la historia cultural africana
contemporánea con motivo del aniversario
25 de la muerte de esta artista que
inventó el Afrodita nuestra periodista
especialista en cultura nos ofrece un
recorrido por su trayectoria
vamos primero a la República democrática
del Congo el movimiento m23 formado por
antiguos Soldados del ejército congoleño
lanzó una ofensiva en el este del país y
desde entonces no cesa de ganar terreno
Los Insurgentes que habían dejado las
armas en 2013 antes de retomarlas a
finales de 2021 se encuentran ahora a
tan solo unos 40 kilómetros de la ciudad
de Roma la principal de la región
provocando la huida de decenas de miles
de personas en esta ciudad precisamente
muchos jóvenes dicen estar dispuestos a
ir a la guerra mientras el presidente
congolenio félixchicekelli y llamó
durante un discurso a la nación a formar
grupos de vigilancia para defender el
país para analizar la situación hablamos
con el investigador josep Arroyo quien
nos explicó Quiénes son los miembros del
M 23 y sus reivindicaciones
el m23 es un grupo armado cuyos orígenes
se remontan al 2012 y sus raíces es
decir los actores que han formado parte
históricamente de este Movimiento
Político militar se remontan a los
orígenes de lo que podría ser denominada
la Primera Guerra Mundial africana la
Primera Guerra de la República mecánica
del Congo o incluso también sobre todo
en la Segunda República en guerra la
segunda la segunda guerra que enfrenta a
los diferentes actores de la región en
1998 en la República democrática del
Congo es decir los antecedentes de este
grupo armado el m23 que nace en
2012 intentando tomar la capital de
kibunorte coma
reivindicando que la población vaya
Ruanda es decir la población ruandesa
que vive en los territorios de tribu
Norte kibusur
marginada esta discriminada está
perseguida y por tanto de alguna forma
reivindica este grupo armado la
protección de esta población civil
Aunque conocemos los orígenes de este
grupo armado que se remontan como decía
a las anteriores a los anteriores ciclos
de violencia que ha vivido que ha
sufrido la República democrática del
Congo y que se remontan a los años 90
el especialista también nos explicó qué
intereses Podría tener Ruanda en
financiar y armar a los insurgentes
porque Ruanda tiene diferentes intereses
en esta zona en primer lugar Porque
estos grupos armados son su bufferson su
su digamos
su muro para frenar ataques y acciones
armadas por parte de actores armados
presentes en el este de la República
democrática del Congo que fueron en su
momento en el año 94 responsables del
genocidio en Ruanda el F de leer las
fuerzas democráticas de liberación de
Ruanda sigue activo intentando llevar a
cabo acciones armadas contra Ruanda en
segundo lugar
Ruanda se ha beneficiado activamente de
la debilidad de las de los cuerpos de
seguridad en el este de la República
democrática del Congo y ha facilitado
que los grupos armados aliados en la
zona grupos humanos locales puedan
continuar extorsionando
de las y explotando y beneficiándose de
la explotación ilegal de los recursos
naturales de la República democrática
del Congo En tercer lugar Ruanda siempre
ha tenido una política de intentar
que los actores políticos y militares en
el este de la República democrática del
congrel se han favorables a sus
intereses y en este sentido debilitar a
los actores armados locales y fortalecer
a los actores que están
combatiendo activamente
a los cuerpos de seguridad con goleses
es una forma de debilitar
las acciones que llevan a cabo el
ejército con goles contra los intereses
ruandeses
en otras noticias más de 40.000
participantes están reunidos en la
ciudad de Egipto para la Cope 27 la
Cumbre de acción contra el cambio
climático que tiene lugar en un momento
crucial y urgente seis años después de
marrakech en Marruecos la copa está de
vuelta en suelo áfricano sus
conclusiones serán cruciales para este
continente que se ve particularmente
afectado por las catástrofes climáticas
Pese que a sus 54 países en conjunto han
contribuido muy poco en la emisión de
gases contaminantes a la atmósfera a
continuación el mensaje de Evelyn
activista un grandeza por la justicia
climática
responsable de menos del 4% de las
emisiones mundiales de CO2 pero es la
región más afectada así que tenemos que
exigir a los líderes mundiales que
proporcionen la financiación para el
clima que prometieron ya hace más de
años para dar a la gente en las medidas
de adaptación y de mitigación y también
para exigir la implementación de un
mecanismo para las pérdidas y los daños
porque está claro que ya están
ocurriendo la gente está sufriendo las
catástrofes están sucediendo por eso
estoy en esta cop para plantear estos
demandas para hablar en nombre de la
gente que no puede estar aquí
[Música]
cambiamos de tema hace 50 años que la
cuti inventó en la afrovit
desencadenando una Revolución musical y
política que inspira hasta hoy en África
Y más allá del continente
falleció hace 25 años y con ocasión de
este aniversario repasamos su
trayectoria con nuestra periodista
especialista en cultura lea Israel lea
bienvenida África 7 días para empezar
Quién era felakuchi bueno pocos son los
artistas que están en el origen de un
género musical el primer ejemplo que nos
viene a la mente es el reggae con Bob
Marley y llegó feracuti nació en 1938 en
Nigeria en una familia de la burguesía
con un padre pastor y una madre artista
política nacionalista trompetista y
pianista de formación Se enamoró del
jazz que descubrió en Londres en 1958
cuando se fue a estudiar allá de vuelta
a la voz inventó un nuevo estilo con el
baterista tunialen el afrovich una
mezcla de jazz solo Funky y ritmos
nigerianos pero fue otro viaje que
cambió para siempre su visión del arte
en 1969 en Estados Unidos conoció al
free jazz pero sobre todo descubrió a
los black panthers Y a partir de este
momento su pueblo que debía ser el
afrovich no solo una música para hacer
bailar a la gente lo que ya hacía antes
sino una música con el mensaje un
mensaje real y un mensaje pan
africanista fue la cuchillera también
una imagen un rostro el cuerpo marcado
por los golpes de la vida una historia
densa y una gran ambición será el primer
músico en llegar a ser presidente de
Nigeria pero su cuerpo debilitado por el
sida perdió la batalla en 1997 a los 58
años y podría explicarnos Por qué el
Afrodita el estilo musical que creó
felacuti es revolucionario
alimentar la probabilidad hace medio
siglo fue la cutis sacó a la luz todo un
continente musical una Revolución
rítmica y política que todavía resuena
hoy mucho más allá de las fronteras
africanas llevó el jazz a África lo
adaptó a los ritmos del continente y al
contexto político de las Naciones
africanas ofreció al público una
experiencia única de energía y de trance
durante sus conciertos la gente
descubrió que se podía bailar y pensar
al mismo tiempo y justamente para rendir
homenaje a la Afrodita y al legado de
felacuzzi en la música La Fiera armonía
de le dedica una gran exposición que se
llama rebelión afrovit abrió sus puertas
Hace unos días y se puede ver hasta el
11 de junio de 2023 en París en esta
ocasión nuestra colega de la cadena
hermana en inglés Marjorie age
entrevistó a su nieto y su hijo
femiguchi lo escuchamos
fue probablemente el mayor compositor y
cantante de África en el siglo XX su
música inspiró a su generación a las
generaciones que le siguieron todo el
mundo se sigue preguntando Cómo este
hombre podía inventar melodías tan
dulces políticas y a veces divertidas
todo ello con una gran conciencia de la
sociedad en la que vivía también
podríamos hablar de su Estilo de vestir
Era realmente único
[Música]
era un guerrero cada vez que lo
derribaban se levantaba con su música y
volvía a lucharse cuando pensabas que
estaba deprimido estaba componiendo
música Ahí estaba Su batería su bajo
podías verle entrar en trance cantando
sus letras nada más de escribirlas sabía
que estaba en problemas no arrestaron lo
golpearon su madre incluso murió pero
era pelada
[Música]
no era solo un músico era una figura de
la lucha política y social en su país y
en todo el continente cuáles fueron sus
causas exactamente ya mal Primero
feracutí era un militante de la
africanidad se negaba a imitar a
occidente burlándose por ejemplo en sus
canciones de todos esos africanos que
llevaban traje y corbata a pesar del
calor y segundo fue la cutie erigió como
misión hablar En nombre del pueblo
utilizo en sus canciones la lengua del
pueblo El pillín english una especie de
criollo que se habla principalmente en
los suburbios de lagos pero también en
el resto de Nigeria más de 69 millones
de personas lo hablan en el país lo que
representa al menos el 50% de la
población entonces utilizo este idioma
para cantar sobre las injusticias que
sufría el pueblo los escándalos de
corrupción las acciones de los militares
y el des colonialismo aprovechaba
también el escenario para la actualidad
entre dos canciones pero la política fue
un combate que fue la cuchi vivía
también afuera del escenario en aquella
época eran las juntas militares las que
hacían las leyes y el poder lo veía como
un líder peligroso fue encarcelado
muchas veces incluso torturado los
militares mataron a su madre incendieron
su casa golpearon a sus amigos pero
nunca se rindió decía una frase que eres
muy bien su vida según mi punto de vista
music is the weeping of the future la
música es el arma del futuro
habría miles de cosas más que decir
sobre felacuti gracias a lea por
compartir algo de ello con nosotros Nos
despedimos con una canción de su nieto
madre cuchi uno de los artistas que
perpetúa el legado de celacuzzi
[Música]